a lot to get to today but quickly
today's episode of hatred mail quick
reminder what is hatred mail because
thoughts and prayers are bulletproof
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom all right and needing
absolutely no introduction here is this
week's Patriot mail with a very specific
conspiracy theory about what is
happening on our program
how can you subscribers to this
pac-man's channel not see how completely
fake years
the colors are all acting they are
plants those aren't average people off
the street just calling in do you really
think for one second that the man
pac-man just talked to actually listens
to the Pakman show to even know the
number to call in this is all fake
people stop giving your money to the
sleazy beta mail since he says he always
goes to the source it was only a matter
of time right until we became the
subject of the conspiracy theories and
it has happened the callers are just
random people
we have caller ID if someone calls in
once we put their name into the system
so if they call again I know when they
are calling but that is all that is
going on with the callers they are not
planted actors there is no conspiracy to
make conservative sound dumb or anything
else that is it remember you can fight
hate reott ism by using the coupon code
hey tree at 40 when you sign up for a
membership at join pakman.com the coupon
code hatred for tea will save you 40%
and it is like a middle finger to the
hey tree it's I recommend using it why
not